STEPHANIE WONG: We're talking
about Kubernetes, reCAPTCHA,
and AppSheet.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
Working with Kubernetes often
means working with YAML,
and custom resource
definitions can
introduce even more complexity.
That's why we wanted
to let you know
about Cloud Code's expanded
support for Kubernetes CRDs.
Cloud Code supports IDEs
and helps you write, run,
and debug cloud-native
applications,
and now also supports inline
documentation, completions,
and linting for both
popular and custom CRDs.
Web traffic is at a record high,
but for more than just humans.
Traffic from automated
systems is also on the rise.
And while not all
bots are malicious,
you can keep your business
secure with reCAPTCHA
Enterprise.
Enterprise introduces better
security, risk analysis,
and abuse protection without
making your users select which
squares contain a stoplight.
See how it works, and
keep your system secure.
Google Workspace is all about
collaboration and staying
productive.
AppSheet lets you take
that one step further
by letting you build
no-code custom apps,
or you can use Apps Script
to extend and modify
with some quick code.
Use either or both to
do more, and if you're
looking for how to get
started, take a look
at the solutions gallery
for some examples.
Finally, thanks for
sticking with us as we
brought you the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
It's been a fun challenge making
our content from our own homes,
so we're giving the team
a well-deserved break.
This is the last episode of the
year, and This Week in Cloud
will be back in 2021.
If you want to read more
about these announcements,
check out the link in
the video description.
And feel free to continue
sharing your thoughts and ideas
by commenting or tweeting us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.